I'M FEELING SICK,
SO I NEED YOU TO WORK MY DESK
FOR THE REST OF THE DAY.
- UGH.
YOU LOOK HORRIBLE.
- WELL--
- YEAH.
ABOUT THAT, I CAN'T,
NOT TODAY.
CODE OF RONIN
COMES OUT TONIGHT,
AND I GOTTA SAVE A SPOT IN LINE
AT THE VIDEO GAME STORE.
ACTUALLY, I WAS
JUST ABOUT TO LEAVE.
CHECK IT OUT.
- THAT'S GOOD FORM.
- NICE.
- HUH? I'M GONNA
PUT 'EM IN THE BATHROOM STALL,
TELL EVERYBODY I'M CRAPPING
THE REST OF THE DAY.
- OKAY, WELL,
I CAN'T LIE TO YOU GUYS.
I'M NOT REALLY SICK.
I JUST--
I TOLD ALICE THAT,
SO I COULD LEAVE EARLY
TO GO SEE WALKING WITH
DINOSAURS: ARENA SPECTACULAR.
- UH, MAYBE ONE OF THESE GUYS
COULD COVER FOR YOU.
- I REALLY SHOULDN'T.
IT WOULD SET A PRECEDENCE
IN THIS OFFICE
THAT WE DON'T NEED.
- NO, FOR ALICE?
WE'D PROBABLY END UP
FUGGIN' ALL DAY,
GET NO WORK DONE.
- PLEASE, BLAKE.
I MEAN, MY LIFELONG DREAM
IS TO LIVE
IN JURASSIC PARK TIMES.
- 1993?
- PLEASE, I REALLY NEED THIS!
I NEED IT!
OKAY?
[quivering]
PLEASE, BLAKE!
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, YEAH.
- OH, OKAY, GREAT.
- YEAH, YEAH.
- THAT'S
ALICE'S APPOINTMENT BOOK.
- OKAY, SURE,
APPOINTMENT BOOK.
- [screeches]
- [growls]
- HAVE A LOT OF FUN.
- GET OUT OF HERE.
- JILLIAN, FEEL BETTER.
- OH, NO.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY SICK.
SO WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT MY FACE EARLIER WAS--
IT WAS RUDE.
- NO GAME.